good morning John I have some very bad
news and it has no effect on your life
or anyone elses lives only mine my life
has been ruined I'll show you what ruin
did this ah yes indeed my loving brother
that is how angry I am angry enough to
deface my MacBook oh look I'm back in
the outside camera because I deleted the
video that I made for you back in
Missoula Montana and not at Hotel in
Maine getting ready to take off at I'm
serious
4 o'clock in the morning tomorrow this
sucks
I'm so sorry well I site video you can
take that as a dramatic what are you
doing stop changing colors like that
stop it
just normal make me normal why does
everything going wrong one video with
the I side Cameron that can be taken as
a dramatic statement about the
disconnect between me and my normal
lifestyle 2 videos with the iSight
camera is just ridiculously
unprofessional and I apologize
[Music]
this weekend I was hanging out a lot
with my nephew Jesse and he had a
balloon tour that you go boom boom boom
boom boom and he was playing with it and
then he hit it on a cactus or something
and it would and Jesse looked at it odd
the string was hanging off he was
looking at it he's three and he said
he's like it it's and I looked at Jesse
and I was like Jesse that's just part of
life all things are ephemeral and for
some reason I just like talking to
three-year-olds that way what he wants
to hear is cookie and what I say is this
is a lesson on the ephemeral nature of
all things well let me tell you what
when I wrote estat my video had vanished
I didn't want a lesson about the
ephemeral nature of all things I didn't
even want a cookie I wanted to throw
that microwave oven right there out of
the window of the hotel room and that is
a lesson that I learned today also
because of staycation and this is what
happens to me on vacation let me give
you one final bit of brain crack to end
up this impromptu video you know how
sometimes you're taking a nap and you
wake up right at the precise right
moment and you feel awesome totally
refreshed and you're ready to get up and
charge out the door sometimes this even
happens to me after a long night's sleep
and then sometimes I'll wake up and I'll
be like no this is wrong this is Bob I
think this has something to do with
sleep cycles and what I want is like a
wristwatch or something on my head that
can tell what sleep cycle I'm in and
then wake me up the precise right moment
when I'm right coming out of REM sleep
or I don't know I'm not a sleep
scientist I just want it to wake me up
at the right time in my sleep cycle I
also wanted alarm clock that could wake
me up with a sound of cooing pigeons
that is the noise that I want to wake up
to why is it so hard to have a pleasant
noise that wakes you up every alarm
clock I've ever had in my life makes
this noise me me me me boy I want to
wake up and I'm a particularly [ __ ]
no John I will see you soon